nature is all life on Earth from trees
to insects from seas to rivers she is
everyone and without her we simply can't
exist she cleans our air she provides
the food we eat and the water we drink
and our economies depend largely on
nature but we have been destroying her
for decades and we are now at a breaking
point it's time for us to act we must
stop the imaging our land and seas and
work to restore them
we need more protected areas we need
farming that's closer to nature and
energy systems that do no harm this is
why we have just adopted a new
biodiversity strategy to make sure
nature thrives again we are taking
several targeted actions to ensure our
society chooses a greener more
sustainable path by doing that will also
contribute to fighting climate change
and we are protecting our health nature
is our best ally from our environmental
challenges helps us build a more
resilient society to achieve this we
need all new countries on board but we
also need people like you to stand up
for nature because we need nature in our
lives today more than ever